Okay, listen, it brings me no great joy to
tell you that I knew this would happen.
I knew antisemitism would rear its ugly head
against impeachment witness. Lieutenant Colonel
Alexander Veneman. As soon as I found out
when I was prepping for yesterday's hearings,
reading his bio that he's Jewish, I just knew
that this was going to happen. Alexander Veneman,
his family is a Jewish family from Eastern
Europe that immigrated to the United States.
Much like my family moved from Eastern Europe
to Argentina. Then subsequently my parents
moved to the United States. It's a very sort
of similar and common, uh, um, uh, historical
element for many Jewish families. And there
is also a common antisemitic trope in very
general terms about Jews, which is the theme
of dual loyalty. It's either dual loyalty
to where you live and to Israel. Even if you've
never been to Israel, as is the case for many,
many Jews. Sometimes it's dual loyalty to
the country you live and your birth country
for Veneman, it happens to be the country
of Ukraine.
And that disgusting Republican lawyer who
has been doing the questioning, Steve caster
or Steve castor oil as I refer to him, uh,
he brings it up. And this is a section where
Republican council is just repeating over
and over that Veneman had been offered a position
with the Ukrainian government to foment this
idea of dual loyalty absent any evidence and
ignoring of course the reality, um, that Veneman
is an active service military member for the
U S that he was blown up in 2004 in Iraq,
although as he said yesterday, very respectfully,
did not get injured nearly as badly as other
people that were with him. And this is the
dual loyalty trope that Steve caster tries
to push
after I spoke to, and I believe it was, uh,
the deputy, um, our deputy senior director,
John Erath was there. Um, I spoke once, I
mentioned it to both of them. I don't believe
there was ever a followup discussion. Okay.
Um, so it never came up with dr Copperman
or Dr. Hill following that conversation I
had with Dr. Hill. I don't believe there was
a subsequent conversation and I don't recall
ever having a conversation with dr Copperman
about it. Okay. And did you brief a doctor
or, sorry, director Morrison when he came
on board? No, I completely forgot about it.
Okay. And subsequent to the may trip, did
mr Danny look ever ask you to reconsider?
Are there any other offers?
No. Okay.
Uh, when he visited for the July 10th meeting
in, um, with ambassador Bolton, did it come
up again? It never came up again. Okay. Uh,
and did you ever think that possibly if this
information was, um, you know, got out that
it might create the, at least a perception
of a conflict that the Ukrainians thought
so highly, I've yet to offer you the defense
ministry post? Um, you know, on one hand,
but on the other hand, you're responsible
for Ukrainian policy at the national security
council. So frankly, it'd be a, it's more
important about what my, my, my American leadership,
American training command, uh, thinks then
any of the, and this is a, these are honorable
people. I'm not sure if he meant it as a joke
or not, but it's much more important what
my, uh, my civilian, uh, white house, national
security council chain of command thinks more
so than anybody else. And frankly, if they
were concerned about me being able to continue
my duties, uh, they would've, they would've
brought that to my attention. Dr. Hill, uh,
stayed on for several more months and we could
continue to work to advance us all seem,
this is a straight up old antisemitic trope.
The dual loyalty of these crafty, untrustworthy
Jews. They might have citizenship here or
there, but loyalty is to their religion over
country or loyalty is to their home country
over their new country. And it comes in many
forms. It's not even new here. This is the
same sort of suggestion we saw on Fox news
as Laura Ingram show on Fox news a couple
of weeks ago. Remember this,
this is buried in the New York times piece
tonight, but I found it very interesting.
Um, he's there. He's a decorated Colonel by
the way and the Iraq war, but because Colonel
Veneman emigrated from Ukraine along with
his family when he was a child and it's fluent
in Ukrainian and Russian, Ukrainian officials
sought advice from him about how to deal with
mr Giuliani though they typically communicated
in English. Now wait a second, John. Here
we have a U S national security official who
is advising Ukraine while working inside the
white house, apparently against the president's
interest and usually they spoken English.
Isn't that kind of an interesting angle on
this story? Find that astounding.
And you know, some people might call that
espionage. This is what they're doing. They
support the military, but they are taking
an active duty Lieutenant Colonel who served
in Iraq and is clearly telling the truth as
he sees it and saying he might be a spy, he
might be dually loyal to Ukraine or he might
be more loyal to Ukraine. It seems he might
have alterior motives here. This will not
stop until we remove them. They will not stop
until we put them out of office. They cannot
challenge the facts. So they attack the messengers
in every way. What are they wearing? How do
they talk? Who did they vote for? Where were
they born? What loyalties might they have?
It is disgusting to watch and they don't really
support the military. The military are merely
props to Republicans to be used this way or
that way.
However, it's convenient and this is getting
into the disloyal Jew territory that has been
so ugly for so long all over the world. Now,
Gordon Sunland is also Jewish, and as we are
filming the Gordon Sunland testimony is still
going on and Sunland his opening statement
was devastating to Trump. Giuliani and all
of them throwing everyone under the bus saying
this was not some vague thing nobody knew
about. This was a clear bribery attempt. Explorative
quid pro quo, I would guess we'll see that
between now and tomorrow's taping, there will
have been right wing media, Republican elected
officials. I don't know who, who will pull
some of the same tropes in with Gordon Sunland.
They won't say it's because he's Jewish, but
it will just so happen that once again, when
it's a Jewish person that we owe it to. Who
are they actually loyal to? We've got to investigate
this a little bit further.
It happened with Inman and it will probably
happen with Sunland as well. We have a great
bonus show for you today. We're continuing
to follow Elizabeth Warren's issues, seizing
control of her Medicare for all position.
Is it too late? Has the ship sailed or is
she still in time to take control of that
ship, so to speak? We will also talk about
a company that wants people to review cannabis
products. It's a full time job and it's an
interesting story about the broader industry
that can be formed around cannabis legalization.
That will be very interesting. I am also,
I didn't, you know could've covered this yesterday.
It's not really appropriate for the regular
show, but so many people emailed me and said,
David, you've got to cover Eric Swalwell,
his fart gate. You just have to that we're
going to do it on the bonus show. A Pat was
insistent that I talk about fart gate on the
bonus show, so we will talk about that.
Well, get access instantly by becoming a member@joinpacmandotcomorbybecomingapatronatpatriondotcomslashdavidthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com
[inaudible].